[LAUGHTER]
>> Jesse: DEMOCRATS IN THE
MEDIA NEVER TOOK TRUMP SERIOUSLY
IN 2016.
REMEMBER "THE HUFFINGTON POST"
MOVE THE COVERAGE TO THE
ENTERTAINMENT SECTION?
THEN HE DEFEATED CROOKED HILLARY
AND THE REST IS HISTORY.
NOW FORMER SENATE MAJORITY
LEADER HARRY REID WARNING FELLOW
DEMOCRATS AGAIN NEVER
UNDERESTIMATE DONALD TRUMP.
>> I DON'T THINK HE IS
INTELLECTUALLY A POWERHOUSE OR
HE IS BASICALLY A VERY, VERY
SMART MAN.
NO MATTER WHAT THE SUBJECT, ANY
ARGUMENT, HE INVOLVES HIMSELF
AND COMMIT IS ON HIS TERMS.
ANYONE THAT THINKS TRUMP WILL BE
BEATEN EASILY SHOULD HAVE
ANOTHER THING COMING.
>> Jesse: MEANWHILE COMEDIAN
SOUNDING THE ALARM ON BIDEN'S
ABILITY TO DEFEAT TRUMP.
>> I'VE ALWAYS HAD I LIKE JOE,
HE'S NOT MY FAVORITE, BUT IF HE
IS THE GUY TO BEAT TRUMP, LET'S
NOT KILL HIM.
BECAUSE IF HE IS THE ONE, BUT I
MUST SAY, MY CONFIDENCE THAT HE
CAN BEAT TRUMP IS WHINING.
HE LOOKS LIKE A DEPRECIATED
STOCK TO ME.
I'M NOT TRYING TO GET JOE OUT,
BUT WE DO NEED SOMEONE IN THE
CENTER TO SAY, YOUNGER, FEMALER.
>> Jesse: UNHEALTHY TO
UNDERESTIMATE DONALD TRUMP.
I THINK THE MEDIA'S RESPONSIBLE
BECAUSE THEY PORTRAY HIM AS
HANGING BY HIS FINGERTIPS OFF OF
THE EDGE OF THE CLIFF BUT IN
REALITY, IT'S NOT LIKE THAT.
>> Greg: TO >> Geraldo: I
SPENT THURSDAY AND FRIDAY NIGHT
IN A CHAIR WAITING FOR HANNITY
TO COME TO ME WHEN THE PRESIDENT
WAS HAVING A RALLY AND A PERSONI
WAS HAVING A RALLY AND A PERSONN
MINNESOTA AND MINNEAPOLIS AND
THEN IN LOUISIANA.
WATCHING IT, I COULD SEE THIS
WAS A GREAT TV SHOW AND THAT
CROWD WAS SO ROBUST, SO
ENTHUSIASTIC.
I'M TELLING YOU KNOW DEMOCRAT
COULD MATCH THAT ENTHUSIASM EVEN
WITH BEYONCE, THEY COULD NOT GET
THAT CROWD AND KEEP THAT CROWD
AS LONG AS HE DID.
HE IS A MASTER PERFORMER.
I THINK WATCHING HIM AND THEN
WEIGHING HIM AGAINST THE
CANDIDATES ON THE DEMOCRATIC
SIDE, YOU KNOW, THERE IS PLENTY
OF FISH IS AGAINST THE
PRESIDENT, DON'T GET ME WRONG,
BUT SHEER EXUBERANCE AND POWER
OF HIS PERSONALITY, HE WILL BE
EXTREMELY.
>> Jesse: ALL THESE REPORTERS
ARE EMBEDDED AT THOSE CAMPAIGN
RALLIES.
THEY SEE THE ENERGY.
THEY SEE THE ELECTRICITY.
ARE THEY DENYING IT, OR WHAT IS
THE DEAL?
>> Judge Jeanine: LET ME TELL
YOU, WATCHING THESE RALLIES AND
I HAVE BEEN IN A FEW OF THEM.
[LAUGHTER]
HAVE YOU HEARD ABOUT THAT?
ANYWAY, WATCHING --
>> Greg: U.N. JESSE.
>> Judge Jeanine: THE DEMS ARE
PETRIFIED BECAUSE THE ENTHUSIASM
IS UNPARALLELED.
NO ONE CAN DO WHAT HE DOES.
SO THEY CAN TALK UNTIL THE COWS
COME HOME.
NOTHING IS GOING TO CHANGE.
THAT IS WHY THEY HAVE TO IMPEACH
HIM TO BEAT HIM.
THEY KNEW IT FROM THE GET-GO.
THE SHAME OF IT IS THE AMERICAN
PUBLIC IS SAYING, LOOK, IF YOU
WANT TO IMPEACH HIM, OKAY, BUT
MAKE IT FAIR.
SO EVERYTHING WILL BOOMERANG.
IT'S A BOOMERANG.
>> Jesse: YOU THINK IT WILL BE
2016 ALL OVER AGAIN POTENTIALLY?
>> Dana: THEY HE WILL SURVIVE
IMPEACHMENT BUT THEN HE'S A LOT
STRONGER.
HARRY REID IS A SAVVY
POLITICIAN.
HE HAS BEEN PUSHING FOR
ELIZABETH WARREN OR HE'S BEEN
BULLISH ON ELIZABETH ONE FOR A
LONG TIME.
HE KNOWS THAT IS A SWEET STATE
THAT THE PRESIDENT WOULD LIKE TO
GET.
EXCUSE ME, I WAS THINKING OF IN
NEW MEXICO, NEARBY, BUT I WAS
REALLY INTERESTED IN THE BILL
MARQUIS.
THERE IS NO ENTHUSIASM.
EVERYBODY IS TRYING TO GENTLY
SAY, EVEN LIKE THE FORMER OBAMA
PEOPLE, THERE IS NO REAL
ENTHUSIASM AND YET, AS I SAID ON
FRIDAY, HE ACTUALLY HOLDS UP
PRETTY WELL IN THE POLLS.
>> Jesse: HE'S HELD ON IN A
WHEAT FIELD.
AND PUSHING GRANNY OFF OF A
CLIP.
THEY ARE SLOWLY TRYING TO GET
BIDEN OFF OF IT.
>> Geraldo: WHAT DO YOU MEAN
BY THAT?
>> Jesse: THICK CAMPAIGN OUT
OF PAUL RYAN.
>> Judge Jeanine: HEALTH CARE.
>> Greg: IT WAS A STUPID
TANGENT ON MY PART BUT PEOPLE
ASKED ME, JOSIE, HOW DID I GET
SO SUCCESSFUL?
AND BEING A WORLD-CLASS
CELEBRITY, I SAY IT WAS NOT BY
UNDERESTIMATING ANYTHING.
I OVERESTIMATE EVERYTHING.
IF I HAVE A 9:00 P.M. FLIGHT TO
MY SHOW UP AT 8:00 P.M. THE DAY
BEFORE.
I UNDERESTIMATE ALL THE
PROBLEMS, I'M EROTIC.
YES, I OVERESTIMATE.
BUT MY POINT IS THIS.
YOU CAN'T DESPISE TRUMP AND HATE
HOW HE TALKS COME UP COURSE, BUT
YOU CANNOT DENY THE ELECTRICITY
OF THOSE RALLIES.
THE PROBLEMS WITH THE DEMS
INSTEAD OF LEARNING FROM THAT
RELATIONSHIP, THEY DECIDE TO
SAY, THEY ARE ALL DEPLORABLE
TOO.
I HATE TRUMP AND I HATE THESE
PEOPLE.
WHAT IS GOING ON HERE THAT WE
DON'T HAVE?
IT'S A HUGE MISTAKE TO SAY ALL
THESE PEOPLE SUCK.
>> Geraldo: I FEEL SORRY FOR
JOE BIDEN.
EVERY PARENT WITH MULTIPLE
CHILDREN HAVE HAD PROBLEMS WITH
COME AND GO.
>> Judge Jeanine: WHY?
>> Geraldo: HE DID SERVE THE
COUNTRY.
>> Judge Jeanine: BALONEY.
HE TOOK HIS SON TO CHINA ON
AIR FORCE 2.
YOU KNOW WHAT --
>> Geraldo: WHAT HAPPENED TO
HIM?
>> Judge Jeanine: HE DID REAL
WELL WHEN HE GOT TO THE
WHITE HOUSE.
HE MADE SURE HIS FAMILY DID, HIS
SON DID.